Hi, welcome to the Anne and Ashley show.
I'm Ashley and I'm Anne.
And today we are going to be talking
about some healthy treat options.
So we came up with two different treats
that would be a great option if you're going somewhere
for the holidays or a gathering in general throughout the year.
But before we get started,
please hit the like, share, and subscribe button
and the alert button if you're watching this on YouTube.
So Anne, tell us about the cookie that you have recipe for.
Okay, so these are chocolate chip cherry cookies.
So the cherries add a nice little flavor and color boost
for the holidays.
But you can certainly make these without cherries if you want.
Just very simple ingredients.
First, we have a cup and a fourth of almond flour.
And then I've got that measured on already.
And it is, let's see.
And again, a fourth of a teaspoon of baking soda.
Dumping that in there.
And then we have an eighth of a teaspoon of salt.
And then two teaspoons of water.
Oh, wait, that's going to go in with the,
so the dry ingredients.
And then the wet ingredients go separately so the water.
I already have an eighth of a cup of coconut oil in here.
So eighth of a cup of coconut oil.
The two teaspoons of water.
And then this is a fourth of a cup of pure organic maple syrup.
So this is your sweetener, healthy sweetener.
Dump that in there.
And then you mix the wet ingredients together.
And mix the dry ingredients just prior to joining them all.
So we're going to, we're going to do this
a little backwards.
Usually you add the wet ingredients to the dry.
My bowls are a little mixed up size wise.
So anyway, even way, it's all going to work.
We're not perfectionists here.
This is real, real baking, real baking, real life first TV life.
Yes.
So if you get that all mixed together,
then you add a fourth of a cup of the chocolate chips.
Or more, I feel like.
Or more if you're a chocolate lover.
These chocolate chips, I found it all these.
They are organic.
They are dairy free, soy free, organic sugar.
So they're all allergy free chocolate chips.
So those are a good find.
And that I'm using for the cherries.
Get the cherries from Trader Jells
who have one in your area.
They have tart unsweetened cherries.
So you put those in there.
And those just add a little bit of a flavor punch
that I think tastes so great.
And chocolate and cherries just go together.
So you mix all that up.
And then you put them in the oven.
325, 410, anywhere from 10 to 15 minutes,
you kind of have to just check out and see when they're brown.
The edges are brown.
And then with the magic of TV drum roll.
Yes.
Oh, why are you not going to stop talking here?
Or the yummy cookie.
Ooh.
Oh.
Don't go on as well.
And they are so good.
And this is a recipe that Dr. Conner's daughter,
Pory, while they make them in their family.
And so this was introduced just by Dr. Conner.
So they are delicious.
They are really good.
We all became addicted to them.
And so now we all make these.
And they're great for the holidays.
Just a good, healthy, clean, ingredient treat.
Yes, that sounds great.
OK.
I have chocolate chip truffles.
So the ingredients are super simple.
If all's your mind, there's three.
So I got these cookies.
They're soft baked cookies.
They are allergy-friendly.
So some of the main allergy-free would
be from gluten, wheat, peanuts, and dairy, soy, egg,
and fish, but they're all, it's free from all of those.
Very allergy-friendly.
If you have people who sends tips of some foods,
then this is an almond milk cream cheese, so dairy-free.
This is made by Kite Hill.
Then we have these are another option of chocolate chips
that you could get.
These are just dairy-free, gluten, wheat, peanut, soy,
egg, and fish, and fish, and cream.
Thank you.
There's a few more things about these.
Those are the main ones.
So these are little mini chocolate chips,
so you're going to get a regular size.
Yeah, so if you need another option.
These three ingredients are just on the side.
So we have the cookies here with a spilling band.
And then the cream cheese in this bowl.
And then you melt the chocolate chips.
So you melt those in here.
So you can make this very easy.
You just take the cookies and you put them all in the bowl.
And then you just mash them up in the cream cheese.
So you can make them as small mashed up as you want
or as chunky.
You want a chunky one.
But, okay.
You get them mashed up as much as you'd like.
And then you just roll them into balls.
You can get those.
What are those scoopers called?
Yeah, I think they're just called cookie scoops.
Cookie scoops?
Or like a ice cream scoop, maybe?
Yeah, or a small ice cream scoop.
You're right.
You don't even have a melon baller.
Yes, that is what I was talking about.
Okay.
Those are big, smaller.
Yeah.
So these, okay, after you get it all mashed up, I'll just use my hand here.
You would use one of those utensils because that makes it look a lot better.
These look like meatballs in these.
Mine did at least.
Anyway, they don't taste like meatballs.
No.
They just are deceiving.
You put some sprinkles on top and you won't think they're meatballs.
So you just make a little ball, put it in the mouth to chocolate, culture them.
My chocolate started to dry.
So this is why they look like meatballs.
Coded in chocolate and then put it on your plate and you're ready to make another one.
And they just freeze them for about 30 minutes.
And then you can just set them out and they're ready to eat.
Well, before they're frozen, you can sprinkle sprinkles on top of you would like to.
But the magic of TV here are the finished products.
So you can make them big or small, this one's pretty big.
Again, they could look a lot smoother if I had that device, but I'm going to do it on
resources.
So these are just nice little chocolate truffles bite sized.
Yes.
And that is all that's in these really simple and easy and the kind of tastes like cookie dough
on the inside.
Yeah.
Chocolate covered cookie dough.
Yeah, really good.
Yeah.
So we hope you enjoyed these recipes.
I hope this helps you with your holiday baking.
Obviously, there's a lot of other kinds of cookies that you could make and maybe we'll
do another episode with some dinger snap options.
So definitely stay tuned for more.
Share this with your friends if you found this helpful.
We all could use some low sugar options this time of year and have the holidays enjoy the
season and stay tuned for next time.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.